warning priggish prevaricator alert
the 14th Amendment Section 3 is pretty
clear it doesn't require that you be
convicted of insurrection it just
requires that you have engaged in these
acts it's a disqualification from
holding office again and it fits Donald
Trump to a t by the clear terms of the
14th Amendment he should be disqualified
from holding office
told you if they were going to pull out
all the stops and that means by any
means necessary you got to dump Trump
even if it means obliterating the actual
words the actual meaning of the US
Constitution now remember as I said in
the angle the Democrats know that their
own base it doesn't want Biden they want
another alternative to run they see
Biden's flagging poll numbers but the
party Elites do not trust their own
voters
under the 14th Amendment he is not even
allowed to run even though he hasn't
been convicted yet instead of
concentrating so much about on the
indictments I mean I'm very excited
about them myself but I definitely think
14th Amendment all the way and just
prevents
well she is a renowned constitutional
scholar joining me now is Jonathan
Turley professor of law at George
Washington University and Fox News
contributor professor
does getting left-leaning State
Attorneys General as Adam Schiff was
referring to getting them involved here
does that give this wacky 14th Amendment
strategy any more heft or credibility
I don't think it does you know there are
there are academics that have thought
about this seriously and have supported
this Theory I think that it's the most
dangerous theory that has emerged in
decades I think it's entirely
unsupported by the text and the history
of the 14th Amendment this provision was
written after the Civil War of an actual
Rebellion where hundreds of thousands of
people died there was an Army on the
other side they had their own foreign
policy that's a rebellion now that
doesn't necessarily mean that it can't
be used for anything that isn't of that
magnitude but it is notable that Trump
has not been charged even with
incitement let alone Rebellion or
Insurrection and yet they say that this
doesn't even require an act of Congress
that any judge can simply announce that
he was supporting an Insurrection and
that he is therefore disqualified and
voters will not get the choice of
whether to vote for him or not that's
what makes this so dangerous I don't
think this will withstand review they
could end up getting a couple of judges
to go with them but in the long run I
think it'll be rejected that's why I'm
eager for them to take it to court so we
can finally put this on the road and see
if they can take it off you know get
this off the ground I don't think it
will I can imagine what Justice Alito
and a few of the others would uh say
about this I mean talk about
anti-democratic this is this is the
ultimate anti-democratic move that you
could think about like it doesn't matter
what the people want whoever the nominee
is if they want Trump if it wasn't Trump
you know DeSantis would be you know
they'd try to charge him with kidnapping
the migrants and sending them to you
know Massachusetts or you know
California I mean you can see that this
would could go in a lot of different
directions none of them good
no I mean this is a comforting tale to
tell liberal children at night so they
can sleep restfully uh that you know
Donald Trump will not be on the ballot
uh but he will be on the ballot and the
thing is this thing was written after
the Vice President of the Confederacy
showed up in Congress to retake his oath
and people were just a bit peeved about
that uh because he had taken that oath
before now we can all have disagreement
about what January 6 was I it was a
horrible day it was a it was a
desecration of our constitutional system
in my view and in a view of it
apparently a majority of people polled
it was a protest that became a riot I
don't believe that it was technically an
Insurrection but the question is should
we just have a system where any judge
can just takes a riot like that and say
well in my view it was an Insurrection
and you aided and abetted it by not
responding fast enough I using rhetoric
that was inflammatory that is a very
dangerous Theory and it would be
replicated over and over again yeah did
we allow it to be accepted to that point
Jonathan Arizona's Secretary of State
let's slip what an important detail
about the broader implications of this
14th Amendment strategy watch this
Section 3 of the 14th Amendment is a
radical and sweeping proposition this
isn't just about one person in One
office this is about everyone who's
running for any office uh in the United
States of America
so look if they can use this against
Trump what stops them from finding that
someone else supported the res you know
Resurrection the Insurrection that
wasn't an Insurrection yeah so you could
see where this would continue to
LeapFrog across other potential races
that's right and the ambiguity within
this theory is quite maddening you know
if Trump had asked people to come back
an hour earlier would that have been uh
not an Insurrection uh would if he had
mentioned go there peacefully three more
times would that have made the
difference we need a bright line rule
after all representative Raskin and
Democrats tried to stop the
certification of Donald Trump in 2016.
when there were violent riots in
Washington DC against his uh his uh
inauguration they had no grounds for
that there were no grounds in earlier
certification fights by democrats does
that mean that they were all engaged in
some Rebellion or Insurrection no it
doesn't we have to have some type of of
brightline rule that guarantees that the
voters can make decisions on these
questions I'm not saying that people
cannot read this as an Insurrection as
opposed to a riot but you have to ask
ask yourself is this what you want
replicated for the future I don't think
it is yeah well there are a lot of
things that were happening after the
killing of George Floyd that were really
scary in the country and Chaos was
breaking out people could make all sorts
of findings the fact about that in
different circumstances as well
Professor wonderful to see you thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else